but I got up and I he said now is it
empty is it empty and I got up and I
screamed oh I'm sort of on a tirade
trying to promote this phone because I
just want to see more films like this
out there as a fan of movies I it was
the first memory that I had it's the
first thing I can think of as saying I
want to be an actor don't you pull that
like you get that goddamn cockpit right
now when you find a great piece of
material or a great script it's like you
should see what happens it's like a
piranha feeding this I don't know where
I got those little balls at 16 years old
to say no I'm gonna I'm gonna wait it
out I kind of felt like I'd already died
and gone to heaven because no one said
anything and I was screaming at the top
of my lungs what the hell is going on
here
he's an American actor and film producer
he achieved international fame with
James Cameron's epic romance Titanic in
1997 he's been nominated for six Academy
Awards and in 2016
won the Academy Award for Best Actor for
his movie the revenant
he's Leonardo DiCaprio and here's my
take on his top ten rules for success do
you remember the audition when you first
met an arrow that was yeah I mean that
was one of those incredible auditions
that came around that I suppose every
kid had been waiting for for a long
period of time because it's just not
that often that you get a starring role
above Robert De Niro in this incredible
you know the screenplay and was you know
Ellen Barkin and Michael Kate and Jones
and was just everyone was sort of
feeding for this role and I got down I
suppose to the final five and there was
like a last sort of day Toby was there
and I I do remember thinking to myself I
got to do something I got to do
something to stand out and in the
audition that was art lence and Michael
Keaton Jones art lesson was that was the
producer and DeNiro
and I remember there was a mustard jar
scene and he had to jam a mustard jar in
my eye repeatedly it was an abuse scene
and the script so didn't call for it but
I got up
he said now is it empty is it empty and
I got up and I screamed Oh like
completely unnecessary but I screamed in
his face and i sat there you know with
my head you know looking like a red
tomato and and and everyone started
laughing at me and then the entire room
de niro everybody was in hysterics i sat
there frozen's thinking oh my god I just
screwed this entire yeah and I just sat
there frozen and then you know Bob and
traditional DeNiro fashioned kind of
just looked at me went and and then you
know we carried on doing the scene and I
think I actually had dinner with DeNiro
recently and he told me no I was the one
who said I was the one who said you
should get to get the job I'm very proud
that it would be like this got made it's
very very very rare to see films that
are this ambitious coming out of the
Hollywood studio system so I'm sort of
on a tirade trying to promote this phone
because I just want to see more films
like this out there as a fan of movies
but as far as awards are concerned you
know the truth is there's a lot of peace
of mind in it because you really realize
that you ultimately have no control of
these things if it's something you hope
for or said after this like I said I you
know honestly I do these movies because
I really love love movies and I want to
make great movies all that stuff is
totally totally beyond your control it
really is I well I did these Jack
Nicholson I'm
as acting turned out to be all that you
wanted it to be it's incredible it's
incredible
you know I I never knew that I could do
it as a career I never knew it was the
first memory that I had it's the first
thing I can think of as saying I want to
be an actor to my parents and if I
hadn't lived in Los Angeles and been in
such close proximity to sort of the
mecca of moviemaking if I didn't have
parents that said okay we'll drive you
to auditions we didn't have the economic
means to you know move camp from Idaho
to Los Angeles because some snotty
ten-year-old kids is how I mean we did
it night after school I got to go on
auditions but it was always and I've
said this before it felt like an elite
group of people and it felt like I would
never belong to them so once I got the
opportunity to to for example get the
movie this boy's life with Robert De
Niro I said Wow now I'm able to not be
able to steer the course of my career I
might be able to have a career similar
to these guys that I'm you know I so
admire and that I knew what 15 years old
was the biggest gift in the world and
that that's that's never left me you
know I've never I've never met that
thirst or that hunger for wanting to
give one great performance that I'm
truly satisfied with or being one movie
that I said I love this film is
something that I don't know will ever be
quenched I don't know and that's I think
that that's a good thing because it
keeps making it keeps pushing you you
know cause it's not lis dissatisfied in
other words I mean I never went to a
formal acting I was only until really
the Aviator that I started working with
Larry Moss who you know it was it was
the first film that I uh I had produced
that I had thought of it was sort of my
concept and I felt like I needed to
brush up on
I'm on the run my technique so that's
what I really started doing formal
training and he was he was a it was an
amazing experience with him I mean he
was it was more than learning how to be
a better actor he was a life coach it
was like he's like over the first day he
was like all right you want to you want
to go over the stuff I'm like yeah yeah
let's do it he's like okay you're Howard
Hughes you're and you're you're playing
this is your cocoon this is your
sanctuary show me how you fight a plane
I'm like well I haven't really he's like
come on don't you know basically sit in
that chair and do it for me right now
I'm like well I haven't quite prepared
he's like don't you pull that he's like
you get in that goddamn cockpit right
now and you show me who the hell Howard
Hughes is you do in front of me right
now I'm like okay I mean and and from
there we you know we started working on
breaking down this script in a way that
I'd never had had before I have to say
I'm impressed because most people you
know don't get an Oscar nomination and
have like many hit films behind them and
then choose to go see an acting coach I
think everyone can always you know brush
up on their technique it is you know
what we do is takes a lot of research a
take I mean if you really want to
inhabit a role it takes oh it takes a
lot of work and training and I think
it's incredibly important to constantly
no matter what how successful you are
it's incredibly important you know what
gives me strength all the time is to be
able to have formulated a group of
people around me that are my friends and
my family you know those two words are
meshed in my opinion but it's given me a
grounding that as insane as my life can
be sometimes is always refreshing and
they're always so honest with me and I'm
so thankful for that everything at the
end of the day when you're making a
movie starts with the material and and
at how well written the script is I've
never seen a silk purse made from a
sow's ear I've never seen it happen
where in a crap script with crap
characters a director somehow
the way to make a masterpiece out of it
and that's the constant struggle that we
all sort of have his actors is finding
those gems and that's why people grab
onto them like vultures when you find a
great piece of material or great script
it's like if you'd see what happens it's
like a piranha feeding everyone wants it
being an actor is the first thing that I
remember wanting to do in life
I remember at 14 15 years old watching
some classic films not well spending
months and months watching all the great
classics all the great performers of the
past and being so incredibly inspired by
them and saying to myself one day I want
to come close to doing something that
good so that I think that that thirst or
that drive to just achieve what I
believe is something as good as you know
those heroes that I have is what
continues to make me want to want to do
this after this boy's life you went on
to play
Arnie grape and What's Eating Gilbert
Grape and this was a turning point I
this was a turning point in a lot of
ways because I understand you actually
turned down another movie just for the
opportunity you you I don't even think
you had an audition lined up for Gilbert
Grape I did have an audition lined up
for ya no I was it was one of those
situations where you know I did this
movie this boy's life and it hadn't come
out come out yet but there was this one
role that I wanted to play desperately
and I but I started to get you know
offers offers from for other movies and
there was a big Disney movie that I
would they wanted me to do and I don't
know where I got those little balls at
16 years old to say no I'm gonna I'm
gonna wait it out because I want to
audition for this other film but if
there's one thing that I'm really proud
of and my my entire career it's that
moment that's 16 to say that you know
and do that and have that sort of
conviction of what I wanted to do that's
the one thing I'm really proud of
because the other movie was an offer
wasn't it yeah for a lot of money at
that time which is
which sounded great at the time but I
said no yeah so you've always been like
a daredevil but you've done I think I've
talked to you about you swim with sharks
or you have yeah and you jump out of an
airplane yeah on a regular basis or week
I only did that one what will you do it
again when you're when both parachutes
don't open you tend to not go repeat
something like that yeah what are you
talking about when then how'd you get
down
I had I jumped out of the airplane and
then my first chute didn't open
they cut its tandem so somebody's on
your back they cut that line we started
free falling towards Earth and that's
when you get the you know eight-by-ten
glossies of your whole life flashing
before your eyes and then the second one
was tangled as well and I saw my friend
sort of popping off with their you know
their parachutes and I'm still
plummeting toward the planet Earth and
and then that was tangled for about a
good I don't know 20 30 seconds and then
he untangled it and then he told me oh
you're probably gonna break your legs
now because this were going too fast so
it was one of the worst experiences of
my life that I'll never heard about and
did you break your legs I did not break
my leg so he's whispering in your ear
are you screaming
Wow that's just horrible so what's the
scariest thing you've ever done I was on
a plane to Russia and the engine
exploded I was looking out the window
and the entire engine just turned into a
fireball it was right after Sulley had
that incident happened to him where the
geese flew into elephant he landed on
that this happened in one of the engines
and I was the I was the only person
there that seemed to see this but it was
a flaming fireball and it was all
Russian passengers and I kind of felt
like I'd already died and gone to heaven
because no one said anything and I was
screaming at the top of my lungs and
what the hell is going on here and
people just kind of look back to me and
the stewardess came and said we seem to
have it a slight problem here
Russian guy finally said what is the
problem I said well we we lost one of
our engines and I said you knows how
many engines did we have
well we had to
[Applause]
he proceeded to say that is not that is
not good there's not work and we
basically dump fuel for 45 minutes and
did an emergency landing and all our
tires exploded and there was a hundred
different ambulances there and was on
CNN and that was another bummer
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Jakob Salem
asked me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave it in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do I'd also love to
know which of Leonardo's top ten rules
had the biggest impact on you on why
what did you take from this video leave
it in the comments below and I will join
in the discussion thank you so much for
watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon
I always felt like an outsider because I
knew of people you know that were in the
industry I just didn't know how to get
into it and I remember going to cast
different agents when I was 9 or 10
years old I was rejected twice I
remember there was like this sort of
cattle call of kids and I lined up it
was like a prison
the photo was like I'm standing there
like this and I had I had this crazy
breakdancing haircut and when I was
breakdancing and I kind of dressed in
hip-hop clothing and they remember they
went yes yes when Timmy went nope yes
yes no and that was it so I got rejected
a couple times and then I just kept
asking and asking and asking I remember
my dad saying just stick with it someday
you'll have your day and I and then I
came back I think two years later and
finally got an agent Meryl Streep and
Diane Keaton or just my two favorite
actresses a long time even before I did
this film and you know Meryl is just
such a presence when you work with her I
mean she throws you so many curveballs
all the time you've got a you've got to
be on your toes with her because you
know she may do something completely
different the next take and you got to
sort of be prepared so you know anytime
you work with people of that caliber
you'll learn a lot